我々は机には生命だとは言わないんですね
命があるんだとは言わないんです
そこで あの 私たちに 私たちはなぜ小さい机と違いますかといえば
心があるんだからとか言うかもしれませんだけど
それ以前 物質的な差もあるんですね
机と私たちの場合は それは何かというと
この体という物体の中で
この５つのまた物質的な働きがありますね
それはこの あの 何と言いますか
眼耳鼻舌身という５つの言葉で言ってる働きなんですね
そういう言葉はあくまでも言葉だけで
この働きのことをよく覚えておいてください
あまり言葉に引っかかっちゃったらもうわからなくなるんですね
あるいは誤解するんですね
言葉の漢字の意味は何ですかと追っていったり
辞書を引いたりしたって何の意味も出てこないんです
で 眼耳鼻舌身というのはパーリ語ではチャックソータガーンジューハーカーエという５つなんですね
チャックっていうのはやっぱりあのこのセンシティビティですか
感受性なんですね で 何を感じるかというと
やっぱり外の世界の形を感じるんですね
色やら大きいやら小さいやら明るいやら暗いやら
いろんなもう我々感じ
それは目というんですね
だから目はあくまでも物質なんですけど
まあ普通に言えば肉体的なもので出来上がってるんだけど
目の特別なこの感受性がありまして
このまあ現代的に言えば光を感じてしまっちゃうんですね
いわゆる光に対して反応するんですね
だから物質は物質に対して反応することはよくご存知でしょうし
で でもだからってどんな物質も
どんなものにも反応するわけじゃないんですね
で プラスチックのような作っているものは大体反応するのは遅いんだから
もうほとんど腐ることはなくなっちゃうし
植物とか木とかはすぐまあ二
三ヶ月間ででも腐ってしまったりする
それは自然のものに反応しちゃうんですね
酸素やら空気やら水やら
でもビニールはいくら水に浸けておいたって全然反応しない
ですから どんな物質もお互いに互いに反応するわけじゃないんだけど
でも反応することは確かに反応します
それは遅かれ早かれ それは別な問題で
それで私たちの目っていうのは
チャックというものは光に反応するということで
それで耳というのは眼耳
耳というものは音という物質に反応する
そういうふうにこの５つの働きは持っていて
眼耳鼻舌身というチャックソータガーンジューハーカーエという５つの物質があって
それに他の物質は反応する
でも反応する物質は決まっている
耳の場合は音という物質しか反応しません
耳にどんな光当てたってのは耳ではそれわからない
体は熱さやらそういうものには反応する
例えば強烈な光を耳に当てたら
我々に光見えるんじゃなくて
熱は感じるんですね 温かいんだと
それは耳ではなくて体なんですね
その場合は 目にでも強烈な光を与えたら
目でそれ見えるだけではなくて
あまりも反応強烈だから反応しなくなっちゃうんです
見えなくなっちゃうし
その代わりに温かみを感じちゃうんです
それが体なんですね ですから
そういう風にまあ重ねてるんですね
目は光にも反応して 熱に寒さにも反応する
痛みも感じる そういうことで
体っていうのは硬さやら熱やら
そういうものに反応する
ですから 体で我々はいろんなものあるということは知ってるんですね
舌取ったら 舌は味に反応する
でも硬いものを噛むと
それは舌でも分かりますけど
その場合は舌としてではなくて体として働いてるんですね
ですから 舌も働き ２つやってて
体全体的だから働きとして２つ２つあるんですね
そういうふうにこの物体の中にこの敏感性がありまして ５
種類の その敏感性あるんだから
生命で生命になってしまっちゃうんですね
机にはその敏感性はないんです
だから机はただの物体だけで
だからこの物体と生命を区別するために
この物質的なこの区別なんですね
今言ったのは チャックソータガーンジューハーカーエ
あるいは眼耳鼻舌身に
舌身というのは物質的な差なんですね
そういうものは机やら壁やら
そういうものにはないんです
壁に目を描けても 描いてあげたっても
壁にはもの見えることはないんです
耳描いてあげたっても
音を聞き取ることはないんです
だからといって 例えば壁が光に反応しませんかというと
それは反応しますよ 音にも反応しますし
光当たると色が変化したりするんだからね
でもそれは認識的な反応ではないんです
それは認識することもあったかいもしないし
で 何か物に強烈な音を与えたら
そのものは壊れてしまっちゃうんですね
我々の体は壊れるということではなく
それは音であると認識してしまっちゃうんです
そういう差ですけどね
そこでこの眼耳鼻舌身に
チャックソータガーンジューハーカーエに反応する物質
をまた 5つに分けてるんですね
それはルーパ サッダ ガンダ
ラサ スパ スパ ポッタッバと言うんですね
で 色声香味触と言うんですね
日本語で で そこでこの理解してほしいのは
この外の世界 外にある物質のエネルギーがこの体に触れたら反応する
でも 外にあるありとあらゆるエネルギーに我々は反応しますかというと
そうでもないんです 外の世界
宇宙の世界ではどんなエネルギーがあるかと私たちにはわからないんですね
大体は いろんなものがあるかもしれません
数え切れないほどのエネルギーの種類があるかもしれませんけど
我々がわかっているのは
眼耳鼻舌身に触れる色声香味触という 5つのエネルギーだけなんです
ですから 我々知っている客体ははその 5つに限っているんです
他のものは知りません
あるかないかも ですから
その 5つの物質のエネルギーの波動として理解しておけばよろしいです
で 大体これでもう生命の物質的な構造の説明はまあ大体それぐらいで終わるんで
だからすごく簡単で ものすごい簡単な説明で
この巨大な この人間持っている存在に対する問題っていうのは
すごい簡単に分析して説明して置いておくんですね
ですから このアビダンマっていうのは難しい教えではなくて
このみんな難しくややこしくしている存在論をすごい簡単単純に分析して
こういうものだよと教えてくれることなんですね
ですから 本当は決してアビダンマっていうのはわかりにくい
すごい難しい教えだなと思う必要ないんです
ただ このいろんなカースが出てきて
そちらの関係なんかを覚えたりすると
ちょっとややこしくなるだけで
それはチャートぐらい書いておけばわかることで
昔の人々は全部一応 1発で覚えておくんですね
覚えておけばそんなに何のこともないんです
まあそういうことで すごい簡単なんですね
ですから もう学生たちに教える教えになってるんです
で そういう教えから考えると
私たちはこのいろんな他の哲学と仏教哲学ね
比べて考えると いろんな哲学の世界では私は何ですかと
存在って何ですかと 宇宙ってどうやって現れたんですかと
何者ですかとか いろんなことを考えてやらしてるんですね
でも最近科学発展するまでは
誰もこの僧侶数的な次元からは考えてはなかったんですね
で それを知になってくると
そんなにたくさんものがあるわけじゃないんですね
そこで現代科学者にはまだそれを知っていうのはたくさんありますけど
仏教にすれば まあそれ 4つしかない
で  4つのエネルギーの波があって
それはもうどんどんどんどん重ね合わせて重ね合わせて
我々知っているすごい複雑な物質構造が
宇宙構造ができていて
それ 宇宙構造の中で人間というものも
動物というものも また幽霊やら神やら何でもいいんだけど
そういうものも出てくるだろうと
で というふうな 解釈なんですね
ですから たとえどんな他の宗教でも神の概念がありますけど
すべてのものに関係なく超越している存在あるんだと
でも よくよく見ると その神にも体があるんですね
なんとなく体があるように感じはするんです
ないとも言ってる人の場合もありますけどね
もし体があるならば それもやっぱり地水火風で構成されている体になってしまっちゃうし
で 体がないというならば
また別の話になりますけど
そこら辺は心の方に行ったらわかると思います
そこで生命というのは何のことなく
ごく普通な宇宙を構成されている物質で出来上がっている物体であって
それに外のある5種類の物質とエネルギーに反応できる特色がある
それだけのこと 例えばカメラを見たらカメラは物体なんですね
カメラも光に反応する
でも音には反応しない
で 私たちの場合 私たちはやっぱり光にも反応して
音にも反応して 味にも反応する
まあそれほどテープレコーダー
マイクロフォンだったら音には反応するんだけど
光には反応しない じゃあビデオにしたら両方にも反応しません
するんではないかと思っても
それまた違うんですね
やっぱりお互いに何の関係もないんです
音を録音する部分が別で
映像を録音するところは別で
別々な行動なんですね
それで一体として反応しているわけじゃないんです
そういうものはだいたい5つまとめているんですね
人間の場合は 生命の場合は
それで生命はみんな全部持っているわけでもないんですね
例えば目がない生命はいるんですね
その生命は他のものに反応する
で 目がない生命には光は関係ない
という風に耳はない生命がいて
耳がない生命には音はわからない
味がわからない生命は結構いるんですね
我々知っている動物でも結構味がわからないんですね
犬猫でも全然味なんかわからないんです
で 鳥とかね よく食べますけどね
ただ飲み込むだけで全然味がわからないだろうと思います
ですから これは美味しいや
これは食べられるかということは
他の何かで理解するだろうと思います
もしかすると視覚 視力はすごいすごいんだからね
鳥の場合は ですから 見て美味しいと決めてるかもしれませんし
それは私たちはわかりませんですけどね
そこでこの 5つは全部揃っている場合も揃ってない場合もそれぞれあります
それぐらいですね 生命っていうのは
生命の物質的な解釈 物質的なレベルは
で それぐらいと言っても
もうちょっと詳しく説明しなくちゃいけないところはまたありますけど
そんなに大事とは言えないんですね
次にそれなんです 今日は
今日はこのバーワルーパという 2つ
バーワルーパという 2つがあります
そちらの説明なんですね
こっち日本語では性色と書いているんです
まあいわゆるわかりやすく言えば性別を作る物質なんですね
あまりこのバーワというにはあまり名前
あまり意味がないんですけど
まあイッティバーワ プリッティバーワというパーリ語から作っていることでは
バーワというのは性質という意味なんですね
でもこの場合はやっぱりこの性別のことを考えているんです
で バーワルーパの場合は 2つしかないんです
その 2つはイッティバーワ
[背景音]イッティバーワ
プリサバーワと言うんですね
このパーリテキストは違う言葉入ってますけど
イッタッタン プリサッタンというのはおなじみなんですけど
で イッティバーワっていうのは何でしたっけ？こちらは女性と書いてますけど
女性と こちら 2番目は男性ですか
だから女性識と男性識と書いておいた方が分かりやすいと思いますね
仏教ですから この生命という物体の何か不思議な構造っていうのは
そういう 2つに分けられることなんですね
で あまりこの説明っていうのは
まあ伝統的な注釈書やらね
まああまりないんですけど
そこまで考えてないかもしれませんだけどね
やっぱり植物見ても他の生命見ても
やっぱりそういう 2つに分けてるんですね
いつでも 2種類がありまして
で 一つだけちょっと取ったら
何かどこかでもう物足らないところがありまして
で そういうことで まあお互いに引き寄せるというかね
引き合うということはありますね
それはもう生命の場合はどこでもあるというふうなことを言ってるんですね
超次元的な人間よりレベル高い生命であろうが
やっぱり体持ってる場合はこの性別はあるんですね
そこでこの性別というのは
これすごいすごい微妙なことなの
それは体全体にあるものなんです
体というものを作られている
小さいカーフで作られてますけど
この小さいカーフのこのまとまりがまたちょっと変わってしまっちゃう
女性識入ったらある形に変わってしまっちゃうし
男性識入ったらまたある形に変わってしまっちゃうし
ですから この人は男性か女性かというためには
体のどんな部分を見ても言えるんでしょう
髪の毛 1本取ったっても
男の髪の毛か女の髪の毛かっていうのはわかりますからね
それ現代的な知識で言えば
やっぱり我々の DNA じゃなくて
何て言いますか トンプソンの中でも染色体ですか
染色体の中でももう男か女かもう決まってるんだから
ですから 生命は男か女かっていうことは
体のどんな部分から取ったっても
まあそれは言えるんですね
そこで体が大きくなってくると
いろんな変化は起こりますし
その変化も その自分がどんな性識持っているかということによって変わってしまっちゃうんです
ですから この性別を作るエネルギー
そういうふうに女性識と男性識に分かれてあって
そんなに難しいことじゃないんです
でもいろいろ疑いするべきところありますけど
このアビダンマの世界では
これから注釈 注釈の世界なんですけど
この一人の生命にこちらの一つしかつけないんだと
いわゆる男性識入ったならば女性識は入らないんですね
女性識が入っちゃったら男性識は入らないというふうに言ってるんです
だから一人の人にこれは 2つもつくということはないんです
それから じゃあ 2つもつけない場合もありますか？というのは
そうも言わないんですね
私は理屈で考えると まあ一つある場合もあって
2つもない場合も可能じゃないかなと思いますけど
そこまでまあ全部生命のことをちゃんと研究しないと言ってはいけないことなんですから
我々には言えないんですね
仏教というのは釈尊の智慧でおっしゃっているものだから
もう釈尊にはそういう能力あったんだけど
どんな次元の生命のことでも
ちゃんと分析してみる智慧があったんだから
普通の人間にはないものだから
まああまりいい加減なことはちょっと言いにくいんですね
まあ伝統的には まあ生命にはこれ 2つの1つしかついていないと
そこでだいたい問題になるのは
このどっちか分からない
ものすごいおかしい人間
人間の中にいるんですね
何者かとわからない 人々もいるんです
それは仏教の戒律の世界ではちゃんと認めているんです
男性とも言えない 女性とも言えない連中もいるんだと
で 戒律では認めていて
この戒律でいろいろ決まりはあるんですね
そういう人は出家はできません
もしお坊さんを騙して出家したならば
もう還俗させて返せなさいと
で それからもしお坊さんを完全に騙して
自分が沙弥戒も比丘戒も両方とも受けたならば
それは無効であると 初めから
ですから お坊さんを騙したっても何の意味もないんです
そのあの儀式は無効ですと
というふうに厳密に決めているんですね
ですから この日常世界ではそれは認めていますけど
アビダンマの哲学的な分析ではそれは認めてないんですね
それはどう説明しますかと
それで問題が出てくるんですね
そこら辺はあまり説明してないんです
それから私は自分で考えているのは
例えば まあ仏教でいうのは
それは男で生まれて女通して生活したっても
それは所詮男ですと そこら辺は問題よくあるのは男性の方ですから
女性にはそんなにそういう問題はないんで
性別ははっきりしてますけどね
ですから まあそういう人々はみんなもうちゃんとした男性です
ですから それだったらなんでいろいろ好き嫌いやらいろいろ変わりがあるんですかと
ということは もしかするとこの性別のエネルギーは性別
これエネルギーですからね
色と物質っていうのはね
そのエネルギーはまあうまく機能しないということですね
エネルギーはあっても
あの完全に機能 自分の働きをするというわけじゃないんだからね
例えば抵抗が高い電線だったら
電気はなかなか流れてこないでしょうし
抵抗は低ければ低いほど電気は何も問題なくそのまま流れちゃうし
そこで超伝導と何とかって物質作ろうと今頑張ってるし
抵抗ゼロのものを作ろうではないかとかね
ですから そういうもので
この何かこの物質の構造で
この女性識や男性識は
まあその機能は十分にフルに完全に機能しないというふうな説明しかできないんですね
そこでこの超次元的に言えば
この神々には性別はちゃんとあるんです
女の神も男の神も別々にいるんです
で 梵天になってくると
性別は本当はないんです
梵天では欲はないんです
体を 体を持って体を媒介して喜ぼうということはしないんです
ですから 梵天に生まれる人々には
もう体っていうのはただ生命を維持するための道具だけであって
体で喜ぼうということはしない
ですから 梵天になったら性別は関係なくなっちゃうんです
そうすると梵天はどうなるんでしょうかと言ったら
アビダルマではやっぱり梵天の神々にはちゃんとこの
何でしたっけ この性別意識があるんだと言うんですね
でもその場合は そこで生まれた人々は
梵天になった人は女であろうが男であろうが
みんな男性ですと 男性意識があるんだと
あっても体は使えないんだから
もう体として何も喜びを得られませんだから
もう香りを感じて ああいい香りだなとかね
音を聞いて ああ綺麗な音楽だなとか
そういうふうに体で喜ぶことはしない
ですから もうあったっても
別に何も機能はしない状態だと言ってるんですね
そこで一旦女性が梵天に行っちゃったら
もう性別はないし 男性になっちゃいまいっちゃうし
それでまたそこから生まれ変わったところで
人間でどうなるんですかというと
やっぱり自分の元の性別に戻るんだというふうに説明しますけど
そういうのは全部注釈時代の説明ですから
別にお釈迦様はそういうことは言ってるわけじゃないんです
ですから まあ認めても反対してあっても
それはどっちでもいいんです
まあそこで例えばそれは男性の方が偉いというための言葉ではないかと思うかもしれませんだけど
僕はそうじゃないと思いますね
なんで女の人は修行して禅定作っちゃったら梵天に生まれ変わるし
なんで男になるんですかと
その場合はやっぱりこのわかる働きあるんですね
女性意識が入っちゃったらすごい力強いんですね
エネルギーは しっかり性別はもう決まってるんですね
で 前も説明したような
もう男性意識っていうのは機能する場合も機能しない場合があるんですね
体は男であろうが 精神的な女の女ですよという人はいるんだからね
その問題はジャイナ 女性の場合はもうほとんどないんです
女性で男性みたいにすごく行動したり
活発的な人はいるんだけど
やっぱりそれはただ自分の生き方だけのことで
精神的に完全に男やっていうふうなことはもうあまりないんでしょうと思います
あまりわかりませんだけど
ですから 梵天が男性意識だけになっちゃったならば
やっぱり性別のエネルギーはどうせ働くだろうと思えるんですね
考えられるんですね 男性意識だったら
それは機能しないで そのまま停止状態にいるということは可能ですからね
ですから より弱い性別を選んで
選ばれて その生命になってしまうということは
別に差別的な考え方ではなくて
客観的に具体的に考えたっても考えられることなんです
ですから 悔しいかもしれませんだけど
梵天の方神々はみんな男性なんです
で 瞑想すると皆様も感じるかもしれませんだけど
どんどん進んでいくと
女性は自分の女性らしさをもうどんどんなくなっていくんです
やっぱりそういう まあまあ
そういうなくなって なんとなくこの超越するというかね
もう悪くなる意味じゃないんです
大体いくら男の人女の人好きと言ったっても
あまりにも女の人はいちいちもうついてくるとものすごい嫌なんですね
あっち行きなさいと と言いたくはなるんですね
うるさいと でもそういうことじゃなくて
なんとなく空気のような感じで
この感じられるような
この嫌味は全くない なんかすごくいい存在になるんです
だからこの あの やっぱり男と女っていうのは
もうあんまりお互いに引き寄っているんだけど
かなりもう喧嘩もするし
もういろいろ問題ありますから
それはもうほとんど消えちゃうんです
だから男と女がお互いにずっと仲良く
もう何も抵抗なしに仲良くしているということは
どちらでも自分の性別的な区別をもう消えていくということなんですね
ですから この修行して瞑想を進んでいくと
もうなんか違う目で相手を見ているんですね
で そういうのはまあ  日本でわからないかもしれませんけど
そういう仏教の国々でも行ってみれば
まあみんな何のことなく
男性も女性もそれなりにいろいろ活動していてっていうことは見える可能性はあるんですね
それは何か消えていくんですね
で この性別エネルギーっていうのは
まあほとんど何のために必要かというと
この子孫を作るためですからね
そんなに大変大事な必要なものでもないんです
うん 何ですか  新しい 英語をしてる
意味 だから意味  ん？ 意味
意味している  はい  どうしてそういうふうに
あの 根本的なんですけど
男性意識 女性意識 性別というものが分かれている
だからそこら辺説明はないと初めから言ったんだからね
事実としてそうであるという
事実として どの生命も男性と女性に分かれていることが多いっていうことから始まっている
なぜそういうふうに分かれている
それはわかりませんですから
僕に聞いても だからエネルギーっていうのはいつでも正と負でしょう
プラスとマイナスでしょ
そうでないと何もものは存在しませんだからね
物質にも物質があって反物質あるでしょ
そういう風に出来上がっていますから
やっぱりどちらか多めになければ成り立たないんですね
例えば物質と反物質は一つきちんとお互いに噛み合わせたらどうなるんです？存在は消えちゃうんですね
プラスとマイナスは 1つになっちゃったらまあ 0 になってしまっちゃいますから
でも我々は 0 の世界にいるわけじゃなくて
ちゃんとある程度でプラスの世界にいるんですね
ですから 負の世界か正の世界
どちらかにいなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことで まあやっぱり 2つに分けるようになってるんですね
なんだかんだで物質さえ
私たちは私たち生きてる物質的な世界はプラスの世界だと思ってますけど
もし反物質の世界にいる人々は
我々のことはもうマイナスだと思ってるかもしれませんし
で わからないし どっちかわからないんだから
まあエネルギーっていうのはそういうふうなもう組み立てですから
性別も一つ まあ同じエネルギーのある現象であって
それはもう同じパターンのを繰り返して作るためのもので
性別は何のためにありますかというと
また新しい生命を作るためにあるもので
生命を作ると心作るんじゃなくて
体を作るためなんですね
なくもない ありますから
そこら辺はだからもう説明ないということを言ったんです
アビダンマでは そこまで考えてない
だから私は勝手に考えて
何かこういうことだと説明していても
それは大変お釈迦様に対する
あの 仏教に対する侮辱になりますからね
私は正直にないことはないというだけで
私もそういう同じ質問を自分の先生に聞いたんだけど
私なりに教えた先生たちっていうのは
すごい古いお坊さんたちで
もう現代的な知識は全くなかったんですね
もう西洋的な知識っていうのはもうまるっきりもうもう 0 なんですね
ですから もうどうしようもないんです
僕は勝手にいろいろ判定
例えばミミズなんかは両性でしょうし
ミミズやらがね いっぱいいるんだからね
海のいろんな生命いて
それからこの地球上にカタツムリとかね
どうかな そうでしょ？両性でしょうし
ですから まあどうするんですか？と聞いたところで
そう 両性であろうか それは男か女なのか決まってるんだと
という答えなんですね
だからそれは違いますよと
私たちにカタツムリに聞いたって
あんた女か男か聞いたって
聞いてもね もうわからないし
それだったら超能力で多人数でその心を読まなくちゃいけない
それだったらやっぱりお釈迦様しかその答えに何か解決する方法はないんですね
でも我々知ってる生命の分け方したっても
なんとなく 2つに分けているということはちゃんとあるんだよ
アメーバにしたっても何かわけがあって
この遺伝子が分裂しちゃうんですね
そのわけはわからない
そのエネルギーはわからないでしょうね
もしかするとそのエネルギーはもう性別的なエネルギーかもしれませんし
例えばミミズみたいなカタツムリみたいな生命をとったっても
やっぱりまた誰か相手をなければ
相手がなければ自分の子孫は作られませんし
両性持っていたって もしかすると男性か女性かに分かれる可能性はあります
ただ 期間だけね 子供作る期間だけ持ってる
だから男の人にでもそういう子供を産まれられるような子宮とかなんとかしちゃったら
別に産めないわけないんだから
だからそこら辺でしょ
例えば男の体にもそれなりの穴があって
あの 何て言いますか この受精したね
卵を産んで産み込めたら
それはその卵は自分勝手に成長するんだから
別にあの寄生虫 寄生虫で寄生虫とは言えないんですね
いわゆるそんな感じでしょ
新しい命っていうのは体につけて栄養を取って自分勝手に大きくなっちゃいますからね
だから栄養を与える いわゆるプランター
プランターみたいなもので
栄養さえ与えればいいということ
私たちはそこら辺大事に考えてるんだけど
そこは違う もうそれはただのもう機械的な働きであってね
医学学でも言うでしょうし
もし男の体の中やって
そういう胎児が成長すると
やっぱりちゃんとおっぱいも出て
そういう変化は起こるんだと
それはもうただの新しい生命の働きであって
自分本来持ってる働きじゃないんです
だからそこら辺考えて
いくら考えたって全然答えが出てこないし
答えが出てきたっていうのは全然別にそれはどうったことないんで
我々にとっては  エネルギーっていろんないろんな面で
いろんなことで二元的っていう使い方が二元的っていうのが根底で進んでるっていう
いろんな局面で  そういう風にはなってるんですね
じゃあそういう 2つがあります
それで性別を決めるんだ
それからもう一つ 注意しなければいけないポイントなんですけど
アビダンマ論というのをどうせ人間研究するものだから
やっぱり人間の次元を中心にして解釈していますので
人間に関係あるものは全部解釈してあって
関係ないものはそこら辺はあまり言ってないんですね
説明したっても ただ何も役に立たない頭
頭で覚えてるだけのことですから
ですから 動物のことも言ってないんですね
我々にとっては関係ないんですから
次の色 ハデーループと書いてるんですね
ハデーループ 心色と読むんですね
ハデヤルーパ ハデヤルーパっていうのは
このハデヤというのはハートであって
この心ですね 心臓という言葉ですね
文化ではね 我々人間の文化ではこの心と
と言うと何か同じ言葉なんですね
心と言えば心であって
心臓も考えちゃうんですね
あれはもうどんな文化でも同じなんですね
英語にしたってもね まあやっぱりハートと言えば
ただの肉体的な 心臓だけの意味じゃないんですね
やっぱり心という意味は入ってるし
日本語にしたっても全く同じ感じで使っていて
パーリ語でもこの心 マインドというね
英語でマインドというチッタとパーリ語で言ってるこの精神的な働きにもハデヤという言葉を使っているんです
でもここでは物質なんですね
心という物質 この今日書いたお坊様方は全然わかってないということは
そこら辺ではもうはっきり言えることなんですね
説明は で これはもう伝統的なものはそのまま繰り返して言うだけであって
この物事をちょっと自分でも考えなさいということはもうやってないんです
ですから ちょっとおかしい説明ありますけど
で あのハデールーパって何ですかと
私の定義なんですけど
これ注釈書にない この注釈書っていうのは古い注釈書じゃないんです
このテキストさえ そういう後で書いたテキストなんです
でも 本当の仏教の基本的な注釈を書いたのはブッダゴーサ大長老であって
その古い注釈パーリ語を訳した人
彼のテキストではハデールーパというところを説明すると
やっぱりヒンドゥー教で考えている
ハデヤっている心臓のことを取ってるんですね
ヒンドゥー教によると
人の魂は心臓の中にいるんですね
魂っていうのは人の生命であって
命であって 精神的なものであって
それは不滅であって というふうな説明なんですね
体が亡くなっても その魂はどこかで出て行っちゃうんだと
だからまたどこかで再生するんだというふうな
このヒンドゥーの教えがあります
それはもう定着しているんですね
そこで仏教にしたっても
魂やら霊やら我やら無いと言うんだけど
心の働きはあると言ってるんだから
ずっと心という働きはあることは明確ですし
それでその心の働きの中心はどこですかと考えると
じゃあ魂があるところに入れておこうというふうに思ったんじゃないかなと思いますね
と思って じゃあ人の心は心臓に
心臓は自分の住みかにしているんだというふうに
で それなんか私はなぜかとわかりませんだけど
どんな人でも私という実感する場合は
胸の方 心臓の方にすごい自然的に行くんですね
日本語で私って そういう風に鼻にさせて言うことはしないんです
あれは不自然的なんですね
私は日本に来て すぐみんな私はというふうに
指で自分の鼻を指して教えられた時はものすごく違和感を感じた
変ではないかと それで日本人みんなそうするだろうと思っていたんだけど
後で実際の世界で誰もそんなことしないんです
誰もそんなことをしたことを見てないんです
でも向こうで大阪外国語大学で私とちゃんとしてくれて
もう日本人ではこういう風に自分を指して言うんだと言ったんだけど
その時はおかしいんだけど
文化違うんだから もしかするとそうかもしれませんと思ったんだけど
やっぱり見たんですね
本当にそうかなと 自分が言う通りに物事を信じないんだから
いつでもへそ曲がりですから
見たところでやっぱりもうもうたまにはあるんだけど
その時 ものすごくその人は自分という存在ではなくて
言葉にストレスエンファシスを入れて言葉を強調して言う場合は
あるいは田中ですと 田中ですと
その場合は田中というその言葉を強調しているんですね
その時は鼻を指しますけど
それ以外はもう全然 じゃあそれはどうかわかりませんけど
他の世界では地球上みんな大体私ですか？といとも簡単に自分の左の胸を指しちゃうんです
何のことなく どんな教えてもらわなくたっても
まあそれはもう医学的には説明できますけど
なぜならばこの左 手はだいたいなんとなく自分の世界であってね
右手は仕事をする手になっているし
ですから右脳ですからね
左手を動かしている右脳っていうのは
感情的な存在に関する自分に関する情報を持っている世界でしょ
右脳は ですから 理性やら客観的な外の世界に対して理屈的なことをやると
やっぱり左脳使う ですから
ほとんどの人間は右利きなんです
自然的に動く場合は やっぱり左は動いてしまうんですね
で 子供たちに何も強引に言わないで物をやらせると
小さい時は左手でやってるんですね
何か取る時でも 何かやる時でも左手でやっちゃう
それでもいい 違いますよと強引に教えちゃうんですね
教えると右手になるんですね
私はもう赤ちゃんの時
ちょっと何か物をつかめる時を思い出しちゃうと
やっぱり自分が自然的に左手は使いやすいのにとずっと思ってたんです
食べる時でも 何か取る時でも
何か落書きですか 子供の描くものいろいろありますからね
ああいう無茶苦茶なことを描く時でも
やっぱり自然に左手で行っちゃうんですね
それでも母やら上の兄弟やら
もう強引にいえ 違います
これでこの手とで食べなさいと
うまくいかないんですね
その時も悔しくて もう左手で簡単にできるのにと思うながら
右手を使ってどんどん右利きになってしまっちゃったんです
もし私は自然のままに放っておいたならば
もう完全にもう左手を使う人間になっちゃうんですね
でも今でも字を書く場合以外は
もう無心的にいろんなことをやると
もうほとんど左手使ってるんです
音楽の場合も結構ね 左手使う楽器はあるでしょ
たくさんピアノとかそんなもの以外は
やっぱり楽器っていうのはもう左手でしょ
ギタリストだって一番大事なことをしているのは左手ですから
ほとんどの楽器です それもやっぱり音楽の世界の人々はね
感情の世界ですから やっぱり理屈ではもうこれダメですということで
で タイプライターはまあわざわざ左手にしているのは早く打てないようにということなんですけど
やっぱりまあ簡単に使えて
私はキーボードとかたまに面倒くさくなっちゃったら
右側のものまで全部左手でやってしまう時まで面倒くさくなっちゃったら
もうこういうのでさ 全部左手でもやって終わっちゃう
今マウスありますからね
もう大体どうせ左手使わなくちゃいけないんです
右手で簡単単純でマウスを動かしたりして
キーボードは全部左手でやるとか
まあとにかくそういう風に左っていうのはね
まあ使いやすい手なんです
まあそれはどうでもいいんだけど
あの まあ心臓になぜなったかということは
心は心臓になったかということは
やっぱりインドではもうヒンドゥー教の影響だと思います
ですから こちら側の説明は別に気にする必要はないんです
そこでいまだに私の説明はしてないんです
心色って何ですかと ハデルーパっていうのは
心書いて色書いたら心色なんです
そこでハデルーパっていうのはまた生命の定義なんですね
この物体はなぜ生命かというと
この物体に心の働きがあるんですね
いわゆる認識するという働きがあるんですね
机と椅子と違って 机と椅子は認識しない
壁も外の世界認識しない
でも私たちは外の世界あるんだと認識する
その認識する働きに心というんです
その心がこの体にあるんだから
そこで体のどこかになければいけませんね
いわゆる まあその説明
一応言った方が早いんですから
この体の中で心の働き
やらせている物質的な基盤
いわゆるどんな物質エネルギーに基づいて心が起動活動しているんですかと言うと
それは心色なんです ちょっと難しい定義なんですけど
でもその定義はぴったしの定義で
釈迦さんの定義はその定義なんです
で 注釈時代の後のお坊さんたちの定義は
心臓の中になんか穴があって
そこにちょっとしたほんのかすかな
ほんのちょっと一滴ぐらいの血液がありまして
そこに心が自分の住処にしているんだと
そんなことはもう嘘であるということはもう明確ですからね
もう我々知っている血液っていうのは
もうただ運搬するもので
もうものを運ぶだけでね
一箇所に留まっているわけじゃないし
細胞にしてもずっと死んでしまっちゃいますからね
血液も全部片っ端から死んでいくし
新しい血液が出てくるし
[笑い]とにかくこの体の中に心が生まれるんですね
で 心が生まれる場合も
我々は体使わなくちゃいけない
例えば我々は考える時は
今はどうせ脳細胞を使ってるということを知ってるんですね
考えたり見たり聞いたりする場合は
はっきりと脳細胞を使っているし
それで物事を感じたり味わったりする場合も
ちゃんと神経細胞が働かなくちゃいけないし
で そういうことだから
もうありとあらゆるところに心が生まれるんです
私の個人的な定義は 心には場所はないということなんです
心に活動する自分の場所というものはないんだと
ヨーロッパ的に言えば脳細胞になってますけど
まあそうでもないんですね
なぜならば 脳が死んだ人もそれでも生きている場合ありますからね
脳死状態になっても やっぱり体が生命として
植物人間としてでも生きているんだから
この生きているということは
この生命ないものにはできないんですね
脳死状態になった瞬間で
その人の体も石のように物体になるわけじゃないんですね
ちゃんと植物人間になっちゃいますからね
なんで植物人間と言うんですか？で
植物はきちんと自分の細胞を新しい細胞を作りながら生きているんだからなんです
だから脳みそだけ心の住みかよというのは
またちょっと良くないし
で 体のどこかとはちょっと決まることは難しいんです
ですから 体全体に体全体どこでも心の働きが生まれる
という風に言った方がいいんじゃないかなと
釈尊の定義はすごくずるいずるい定義なんですね
場所は言わないんです
心が働くこと 心が何かどんな物質をよりどころにして働いてます
いわゆるどんな物質をよりどころにして認識していますか？その物質が心識というというふうな経典の定義なんですね
だから逃げてるんです
場所は言わないで 注釈書ならこれ場所は言ってないんだから
やっぱり場所をちゃんと作ってあげようと思って
ヒンドゥー教の魂の真相にあるんだと
じゃあそれで簡単にどう理解すればいいんで
その場合は 一応この体の中に心のエネルギーは働いています
その心のエネルギーも体に依存しています
私の体なければ何も知ることはできないんですね
例えば人の目も耳も鼻も
舌も体の感覚も消えちゃったと仮定すると
我々にとっては外の世界はもう全く存在しなくなっちゃうんですね
知らなくなっちゃうんです
反応できなくなっちゃうんです
そうすると我々今持ってる知識っていうのは全部消えちゃうんですね
例えば人が生まれた その人に目は見えない
耳も聞こえない 鼻でも何も味を感じない
舌でも感じない 体を触っても全くわからないと
いうならば 私達はどうやってその人とコンタクト取るんですか？何にもできないんですね
何も反応ないんだから
ということは 我々持っているすべての知識やら考え方やら
体を通して得ているものなんですね
体自体が認識しているんですね
瞑想が進まないのは 一つはそういう原因なんです
ものすごく体に我々定着して執着しているんですね
その体に依存することをどんどんどんどん少なくなってくると
その分瞑想が進んでいるのです
このヒンドゥー教の世界で
あるいは他の瞑想の世界にあるこの魂論というえらい誤解はそこから生まれているんです
瞑想すると ヒンドゥー瞑想であろうか
ヨーガであろうか 他の宗教の瞑想であろうか
やっぱり進んだ人の場合は
やっぱり体に依存することはどんどん弱くなって
たまに体に依存しない
しないで認識する経験もあるんですね
そこをすごく驚いて驚くんですね
体あるということさえない
感じない 自分の体を持ってるんだと
それも消えちゃう 消えてでも自分の心は堂々と自由自在に働いている
それをみんな魂やと それは霊魂だと
それはもう人間の霊です
魂ですと それは永遠に不滅ですと
いきなり決まってしまっちゃう
その決まるのは何も証拠なく
もう判断したがる癖があるんだからね
いつでもすぐ判断したがっちゃうんですね
これはこうだからこうですよと
でも仏教ではもう判断というのは全く不可能な認識論を言ってるんだからね
判断というのはあくまでも偏見であって
partial view であって
ある側面で言うことなんですね
あの人綺麗ですよっていうのは
その人は綺麗だからではなくて
自分の見方から見れば綺麗でしたということだけであって
この食べ物美味しいですよというのは
この食べ物は絶対的な美味しいという真実ではなくて
その人の立場から見れば美味しいということです
ですから 判断というのは
その人の立場 その時間
その空間というものによって
いつでも変わってしまっちゃうんだから
最終的な判断というのはありえないんですね
どんなものについても
ですから そこら辺極めると仏教的な瞑想になっちゃうんです
判断しない 仏教とほとんど似ているヨーガの世界はどこで変わってますかと
ヨーガの世界っていうのは
最初から厳密に頑固と判断に基づいてやってるんですね
それだったらもう瞑想自体はサマーディとして進みますけど
智慧は現れないと我々は言うんですね
でお釈迦様もこの最初にこの仙人たちから瞑想を教えてもらったんだから
教えてもらって この禅定
最高の禅定のレベルまでちゃんと普通の仙人たちから教えてもらったんだから
そこら辺は別に問題はないし
それはお釈迦様はダメですよと言ってない
そのお釈迦様教えてもらった瞑想の禅定レベルはそのまま仏教にも取り入れているし
サマーディ世界で取り入れて
科学的に心理学的にそれを取り入れて
もう何も否定してない
でもそこでも解脱ではないと
ということで このこれは判断ミスなんですね
この瞑想体験があって
心理語る人々の教えは全部長部経典の第 1 番目にまとめているんです
64種類の宗教哲学として
そちらではやっぱりずっと言っていることは
それはその仙人の体験は正しいんだけど
その人は超一流の知恵で超一流の瞑想体験で見たものを体験したものはその通りですが
こう決めたところは間違っているんだ
判断したところで間違っているんですね
まあ分かりやすく例えばある人がもう自分の過去生を見る
過去生で見て見て見て見て見て
もう 1回2回じゃなくても
1万回  1億回でもなく
1億年先 また 2億年先とかね
億年じゃなくて劫年ですね
1 劫年先2劫年先までも見ちゃうんですね
先というんですか  backward ですけどね
過去を見るんですね 見て
劫年というのは宇宙ですから
宇宙の年代だから だから宇宙をこの宇宙は消えて
消えた 亡くなった 生まれた時も見て
それ以前も見て またそのこの宇宙は現れる前に
また違う宇宙があって
そこを消えて今の宇宙が出来上がっていると見えるで
それでその宇宙の次元でも自分がいたんだと
それまた二劫年 三劫年とか
また過去を見るんですね
見たらもう諦めちゃうんでしょ？こんなものはまあ
過去どこ見たっても同じことだと
それでその人と決めるんですね
私は永遠である こんな物質はいくら破壊したっても
この宇宙はもう全部消えて無になったっても
またもう生まれるんだから
自分は死ぬことはないんだから
魂は永遠でありと結論出しちゃうんですね
そのお釈迦様が文句を言うのは
その結論になんですね
見たものは見たところで止まってくださいと
あなたは五劫年まで過去を見たんですよと
その見たものはその通りですよと
もっと過去見たら もしかすると違う結論が出てくるかもしれません
ですから まあそういうんじゃないんだと
そこからこのまたまた違うものがあります
どんな人にも自分の過去を見られないんですね
過去があるとしたって
で 見られる時間 次元と見られない次元という
またあるんですね そこでまたある宗教者が自分の修行から経験を得て瞑想して
それから過去を見て 見て見ていくと
あるところまで見える
例えば二劫年まで見た
二劫年の過去はいくら探しても見えない
見当たらない 自分がいたかないかっていうこと
二劫年目から自分が今ずっと生きて死んで生きて死んでいくことはわかっちゃうでしょ
そうすると その人は結論を出しちゃうんですね
私はある日突然生まれた
ある日突然生まれて 一旦生まれてからずっと輪廻は終わりなく転生しているんだと
ですから魂はある日突然生まれるもんだと
生まれちゃったらもう死にませんと
と結論出しちゃうんです
お釈迦様が言うのは あなたを見たものはその通りであるんだけど
あなたの宗教的な哲学は良くないんだと
いわゆる結論だけはもう出せないんですね
それはその人の見方からそう出てくるんですから
そういうことで この瞑想の世界では
この仏教の批判というのは
このもう完全にもう否定しているわけではなくて
それはもう十分認めた上で
この人間はどこで間違えますか？間違うところは直しているだけなんですね
ですから このインドであった瞑想とは全くの違う瞑想は仏教瞑想ということじゃないんです
まあほとんど似ているんです
ほとんど似ているんだけど
まあほんのちょっと もう変わってて
まあそれでもちゃんとした解脱の世界を見つかっているということになっているわけですね
で そんな話になったのは
この瞑想は人間の瞑想はね
もうみんなやるんだけど
進む人はすごい少ないっていうことなんですね
で 我々はこの全ては体から得るもんだと思ってるんです
で その自分の体に対する執着を離れると
第一次禅定が生まれるんです
ですから この五蓋という言葉がありまして
五蓋っていうのは何でしたっけ
この渇愛と怒りと えっとえっとえっと
ティーナミンダはこの昏沈睡眠と
それから情動ということと疑いなんですね
で で 渇愛の場合はもう体に対する欲ですね
怒りも体に対することであって
それから昏沈睡眠っていうのはやっぱり体のことで
寝なくちゃいけないと
寝ること楽しいとかね
これは大変大事ですよと
いちいちうるさく言うんですね
で ということは もう寝たがる人はやっぱり体
この腐っていくこの体にあまりにも執着しているということだけで怒る人もそうであって
欲に走っている人も ただ体を楽しませてあげようとかね
ということだけで 情動っていうのはまた体に関するもので
いわゆる混乱と後悔ですね
いろんなことをあれはやりそこなかったとか
あれやっておけばよかったとかね
まあああだこうだ自分を責めたりする気持ちと
落ち着きがない気持ちですね
それも体から生まれてるもの
で 疑っていうのは疑いですね
まあ体にも執着しているんだから
もう物事はどうせはっきりわかってないんですね
ですから疑うということは当然あるんですね
ですから この体に対する執着を消えたところに第一次禅定が生まれるということで
それは心理学的にこの五蓋をなくなったら第一次禅定が生まれるんだと
という風に説明してるんですね
蓋というのは この妨げになっているものですよ
やっぱりサマーディが生まれないように
サマーディの世界を妨げて邪魔しているものなんです
何が邪魔しているかというと体なんです
そういうことで で 我々の認識は全部体の中に生まれている
ですから 我々の認識は物質の中に生まれているということなんです
で 電気はいつでも物質の中にあるでしょ
電池があって 電池の中にもう蓄積していると
ふうなことで もう何かそんなような感じで
やっぱり体がなければ
まあ心が働かないようになってるんですね
ですから その心の中 体の中で心のエネルギー
認識のエネルギーを支えている物質を心識というんです
あんな説明は長くしましたけど
そんなに長く説明する必要はないんです
すごい簡単です この体の中で
この認識は支えている物質的なエネルギーはもう心識というだけのことです
次の はい  体はワット 体はドゥッカだと
先の原始仏教の時に禅師の言葉にはワットという言葉は出てこなかったんですけど
そこは特に気にする必要はない
いえいえ 原始仏教でワットと言いますよ
ですよね 別にこの説明のところでワットという言葉が出た出ないっていうことであって
別に先の禅師のところで出てきたのパサドゥッパみたいな
そのワット